recently over Thanksgiving Black Friday
there were several outstanding rising
deals and today being Cyber Monday and a
holiday season coming up right now
there are definitely going to be several
more hours to any rise and deals however
despite these savings doesn't make sense
to buy rice and CPU right now but Zen to
being so close
[Music]
so starting off with some specs Zen to
will definitely beyond the seven
innovative process which AMD has
confirmed in Ta'ala that hand is still
on the 40 nanometer process with coffee
lake which just launched like two months
ago and they're so strongly gotten an
Amir process even if they do get on the
10 nanometer process
Ami's n2 will still be the most
architectural advanced CPU out there
places on seven inve process AMD has
officially claimed an IPC boost of 29%
over Zen want to be expected on Zen -
this is not as good as is n1 /
piledriver which was a whopping 52% but
this is still very very impressive as
far as 16 cores go I really just don't
see that coming on to mainstream rising
because it really makes no sense 10
cores maybe 12 cores but even that is
more than what most gamers than the
average consumer really needs so there
is really no need to have that much
power into mainstream CPU also a 10 or
12 core CPU was actually a potential way
for AMD to fight back against Intel if
there were to launch a nice eight core
16 third CPU on the mainstream platform
like 9900 K however the 9900 K is so
expensive that Amy does not need to
lease a 10 or quad-core CPU on a
mainstream platform in order to compete
they continue just macaque core CPUs at
a great price ask for a clock speed the
engineering samples are showing a base
clock of 4 gigahertz and all Corp turbo
of 4.5 years that's really impressive
and that's just an engineer example with
the final product
given sufficient cooling we should be
able to hit four point seven to five
gigahertz especially given the new
smaller production
which increases efficiency overall I
would say that we can expect a 15 to 20
percent increase over is n1 and n2 also
we should see better ramp support as
well as florists release date goes amy
has been very consistent with their
release dates with the first generation
of Rison it came out at the beginning of
March and the second generation of Rison
came out and mid April so for his n2 we
can expect an official reveal of all
aspects during the end of February and
CPU should be hit in a market at March
or April 4th Red River we will probably
see an official reveal at the end of
July and the launch near the beginning
of August but for most of you guys
that's irrelevant
you guys just care about mainstream
Rison so all of that is cooling off but
how much is this going to cost and is it
worth waiting for
well amy has always been very good at
pricing I don't think that's going to
change with sent two with first
generation rising the top model that
1800 X came out for an MSRP of $500 for
second generation risin the top model
the 27 Rx came in for an MSRP of 330
dollars plus the 2700 had a really nice
stock cooler included with it due to
this being a new process and thus
requiring a lot of research and tests
associated cost I think at the top and
CPU at least the top and octa-core CPU
maybe a bit more expensive than second
generation Rison the 3700 X may be
priced at $400
with the lower-end 3700 coming in at 330
bucks and any hired cork on CPU like at
3800 X may come in at 450 or 500 dollars
based on that I really expect the
overall pricing structure of risin to be
about the same as the previous two
generations plus Viton CPUs are almost
always $50 off on Amazon so what about
the competition well at this point
there's really only one main stream CPU
which can compete with the rise in 30
similar bags which it up until I 797
arcade well there is 9900 K but the
price point at the 900 K is being
offered forth which is right now $740
I really wouldn't even consider in a
mainstream sea of you you can get a
rising threat group for 1950 X which has
double the course and double the threads
for a Hungary and retailers cheaper than
nine a hurricane so it really just
doesn't make any sense at all and with
the 97 or decayed into's main lead over
the 27 our Beck's was clockspeed since
the 97 harder case lacking
hyper-threading and only having 8 cores
and threads however with that gap being
closed 37 heretics the Intel i7 1900
acade really stands no chance against
incentive to an 8 core 8 thread CPU at 5
acres
shouldn't lose to an 8 core 16 thread
CPU at four point seven acres in any
given task unless optimization is
absolutely terrible but I highly doubt
that and of course the 30 similar
directs will mostly coming at a cheaper
price than 97k
come with nice stock cooler and be able
to overclock on cheaper motherboards as
a result until the release of Intel's
new CPUs at the end of next year whether
that's going to be ice lake or cannon
lake or whatever they want to call it
Rison 2 is definitely going to be the
best mainstream CPU available and this
time not just in terms of the value but
also performance so that pretty much
covers everything about Zen - so should
you wait for it well if you're looking
for a high-end octa-core CPU and you
don't really care about saving 50 to 100
bucks you care more about higher than
vesting available and you should
definitely wait to present - then do is
going to be absolutely fantastic the
next couple of generations are only
going to be incremental upgrades over
Zen dude
so you won't have to worry about
something big coming out over the next
couple of years however if you're
looking for a solid C DP u that will
last you several years and you would
like to save some money if possible and
I recommend going in and buying a write
and CPU right now over the next couple
of months during the holiday season
because then two CPUs are not going to
be offered at these prices and 2000
series CPUs are by no means inferior
2000 series CPUs are already outstanding
and AMD is just taking it a step even
further but that's pretty much all I
have to say about that so what do you
guys think what clock speeds you think
Zen - will achieve and how many cores do
you think will be on the top end CPU
make sure to post down below what you
guys think because I do it online
comments and I'm curious as to what you
guys think so make sure to post your
thoughts also if you guys like this
video make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing if you like to see
more videos just like this one but until
then I'm all ready I'll see you guys on
next
[Music]